let's pull up this clip ladies and
gentlemen we have a new president it's
Obama or it might be Kamala so Joe Biden
himself has repeatedly said Kamala is
the president and now Kareem Jean-Pierre
says Obama's the president you ready for
this one
okay so today as you all saw just an
hour or so ago President Obama announced
that
the person invited whoa
[Applause]
that is news
okay wait one more time one more time so
today as you all saw just a hour or so
ago President Obama announced that
she is so bad at her job she read from
the paper she's looking at and said the
wrong president's name or
I'm assuming when she's reading she read
President Obama That's full-on symmetry
man because that guy was hasn't been
president but is she reading look she's
real she's reading as she she's that
that's the point so today as you all saw
just an hour or so ago President Obama
announced that yeah she's reading off a
paper she read that that her eyes were
down as she was reading that she's
reading from a paper checked out wow I
think she's checked out yeah she's
checked out I do I honestly like
you know because like no don't no I feel
bad for him because he's just trying to
you know he's trying to chill right she
doesn't want to be transportation and
the government knocks on his door and
they're like Pete booty judge he's like
uh yeah he's like washing a pan and
they're like we need you for
transportation secretary he's like what
it's like your country needs you and
they put him on the helicopter and fly
him to DC and then he's like I'm not
doing the job and they're like well you
are and then he's just trying as hard as
he can not to do it but they won't fire
him that's true he's just like look man
it's like office can you fire me man
that's actually a really great meme can
we do that Buddha judge as the main dude
in office space yes and then you get
like I've got like seven bosses yeah so
what would you say you do here well I uh
go on vacation and fraternity leave
ignore natural and man-made disasters
and
space out for about an hour if there was
like a war and then bombs were blowing
up roads would would Buddha judge be in
charge of overseeing the Reconstruction
of the roads the transportation center
is that all deferred to the military
honestly I don't think it happens yes
anything but yes he'd have some he'd
have some Authority there for sure yeah
because it's National I look at his
National Security if you let the people
of your country starve die off from
chemicals that's a loss of security in
the nation if the U.S was being bombed I
think we'd be under martial law
instantly and the military would take
over infrastructure projects that's true
we wouldn't have a civilian doing it
they might communicate with him in some
degree and have him do something they
would just like Biden might give him a
battlefield promotion and make him
Lieutenant Colonel there'd be some some
photo ops for sure like have him
standing there
[Music]
I gotta be honest though I kind of feel
like if the roads were to be bombed in
like a figurative sense destroyed it
would be because of the Biden
Administration not you know not in spite
of
it's their policies that are going to
result in this so you know they blame
Donald Trump for the the the the the the
derailment but Biden has been president
for two years it's like and they passed
the infrastructure bill with 1.2 billion
dollars for the rails like and then what
did they do with it do you guys think
that Obama's secretly pulling the
strings
I
think he's on a panel that that I think
there's a bunch of people that are
pulling the strings the uh the they
wrote about in Time Magazine the cabal
of Elites or whatever they called it
fortification of Elections yes he bought
a house near the White House
he was caught on Mike saying the only
thing I would like better than a third
term is to not be president again and be
able to basically control this whole
operation from my basement I think he's
doing it that's my honest opinion it'd
be funny if he's like literally in his
basement with a like a beard growing
and he's like just dirty and disheveled
and he's like rocking back and forth
watching the news and then he takes the
phone and he calls Biden he's like Joe
what's up with this smoke in Ohio and
Joe's like I don't know man I'm you know
I think he's got an ifb straight into
bind's ear but bind's hard of hearing so
he's like he just keeps saying the wrong
lines even though Obama's like look I am
one of the most gifted orators of our
time and I'm talking directly into this
dude's ear and he still can't get it
right I feel for Obama ultimately I
think that Obama is is involved in this
now I haven't thought that much because
he's I haven't heard of him much but for
her to say his name like that must that
is so natural you know be kind of cool
actually if like there's a house a block
away from the White House with a secret
sub-basement you know you go in this
regular house and everything looks
normal and you go downstairs and
everything looks normal and then you
lift up like a chest and underneath it
is stairs that goes down into like this
dark Cobblestone brick castle wall and
Hillary Clinton and Obama are wearing
dark cloaks and they're like look
looking over this computer screen and
they're like oh and they're feeding
information to Joe Biden and tell them
what to do I think that'd be really cool
cartoon that I'd like to write it's not
impossible I know basically I believe
anything it would be better if like
Obama is in some kind of pod with a
neural link plugged in and then like
he's got a heads-up display and he's
controlling Biden and that's why Biden's
like all messy because like when the
connectivity goes out he slurs that
explains everything it could be that the
people like Karine have no faith in
Biden like zero probably a lot of people
in that Administration have very little
to no faith in the guy and so Obama's
keeping them keeping their morale up
yeah I got your back if something
happens to him I will be here to lead
this country kind of thing well that's
that's how degraded or our political
classes that like even though everyone
there has clearly given up like it's so
crystal clear that they've all given up
on their jobs they're they're just like
we know we know that the whole country
is falling apart but
we've been told by the business class
that we're going to be taking care of
because we're just going to continue to
do our jobs and then that revolving door
into K Street we're going to get our
payday at the end of it that's I I know
that's a really jaded way of looking at
it but like tell me when you watch
Korean John Pierre speak that you don't
just sense like she is counting the days
until she gets to quit this job counting
the days it's almost like
um they almost dog whistle his name out
like when everyone's like okay Biden's
kind of start like all their base is
like all right Biden's starting to creep
me out she's like yeah yeah Obama and
they're like oh oh okay yeah you got my
attention again I guess you know maybe
it's something to subconsciously tell
them that he's still involved I I would
love to be a White House Press Secretary
because it's like the one job you don't
got to take seriously you know like like
you said she's probably counting the
days yeah but she's she's phoning it in
yeah but she's still phoning it in like
if it were me I would probably not show
up half the time all right yeah and then
when I did I'd bring like a lounge chair
I'd have like a switch and I'd be
playing Spelunky or maybe I'd like set
up a Playstation and just be like I'm
gonna play some OverWatch get some quick
no limit in and Tim Tim and you're like
we have a question about the train
derailment and I'll be like yeah I don't
know anything about it like chicken
analytics I'm not the president dude
like do you think that Karen John Pierre
knows what the hell's going on yeah no
she has she has a binder that's like 18
inches thick just so she apparently says
Obama's the president yeah I don't
believe she's I think she just brain
farted that's the most real I've ever
seen her I don't watch a lot of her
stuff but when she laughs and she's like
oh my gosh what yeah wow so that's news
and here we are talking about her she
looks like she's being watched and she
knows it just think about how degraded
of a human being you have to be to you
all day for months now she's been lying
us into World War III but the faux pas
that gets her to giggle is saying Obama
like she she can just lie through her
teeth about everything in Ukraine
honestly she probably doesn't even know
why am I why am I like she's just
reading off a paper she's Michael malice
needs to be a press secretary that'd be
funny that was the whole plan Dave Smith
malice come on let's go yeah you know
we're working on it right yeah yeah I'm
working on it I'm open to it I want to
bring like Donald Trump together man at
this point I'm like I will run as your
VP I want to sit in with the Senate and
listen all listen on this show I want to
listen to like these people get to know
who they are yeah uh get malice involved
get Alex Jones involved get you involved
get Tim evolved get all these awesome
politicians Dave Smith involved like
everybody I know it doesn't have to be
Donald Trump I don't care I just want to
do this for real and at least try and
steer this mechanism so that we can turn
the liberal world order into the New
World Order effectively with like
delocalized statehood as the central
back we're gonna have to work on The
Branding because we can't call it the
new world order would you what would you
what would you put
Alex Jones in your cabinet where would
you put him
Secretary of War uh Alex Jones I don't
know I don't know what the cabinets
entail how that would work
um probably is like a science advisor of
some sort or at least I would I would
ask him to talk no no disrespect to
malice but I would love to see him as
press secretary my God my God that would
be amazing yeah it'd be it would be fun
oh so fun we just like somebody who
shows up and is just like sitting there
and then point somebody and just ask and
they're like what is the pr what did the
president mean when he said you know and
then insert Gaff and be like out of his
mind like Joe Biden's brain doesn't work
you think Joe Biden knows what's going
on in Ohio and he told me to tell you
what's going on in Ohio is this as well
listen up to it he's got he's actually
just a skin suit been flown in from
Langley oh yeah I do stuff like that
that'd be fun be like well actually Joe
Biden isn't the president it's Obama
that's right all the conspiracy
theorists they were right the whole time
there is seven look if we're gonna press
zero if we're gonna have world war three
I need I need some sort of pick-me-up
like Alex Jones yeah secretary man I
need it I'm thinking like we really do
need to use modern technology to clean
this oil spill or the spill up in East
Ohio like why I keep waiting for someone
to do something miraculous in the
government like okay who's the guy that
has read about graphene technology so we
can stop creating you know planned
obsolescence of roads and rail like we
can build roads that last 170 years
Railways that don't warp you know after
40 or so it's interesting it's it can
can um a private company get involved
and do this or do they need to be like
could they come forward and say because
like we think the military is in charge
of this right now like handling this or
do we think Pete bootage look who's in
charge we don't know we know it's the
government so can can a small business
or a business come out and say hi we
specialize in cleaning this up can we do
anything because nobody's come forward
and this happened what February 2nd yeah
February 2nd or third okay so so it's
been three weeks yeah and the silence is
really starting to get to me I mean it's
been getting to me you can pour iron
dust into an oil spill water and the oil
coagulates around the iron then you put
a magnet in and it'll suck the oil to
the magnet you can pull it out that's
awesome let me black pill the hell out
of you guys right now if there was some
startup business that came up with the
technology to deal with this the reality
is those businesses don't exist to a
large extent because when there's a
disaster like this the government is
going to turn to an industry partner
someone who's already deeply in bed with
them and they're going to give them no
bid contracts to go and deal with this
they're not going to turn to the most
Innovative because they don't have any
political gain to be made there so until
that changes I don't know how you get
any sort of ultimate fix to what we're
talking and that's a good point it's
almost like they wait it out and they're
like all right you know the half-life of
these chemicals are I don't know I don't
know what the half-life is but they're
waiting it out and eventually it's like
okay it's going to go away on its own
and then it's going to look like we did
something to make it go away Tucker was
talking with Ben Shapiro I'm not sure
when this was but I saw a clip going
around I need to ask bye Ben Shapiro
would you if you're in government stop
self-driving trucks and he goes
absolutely I'm not going to put 10
million working-class men out of J out
of a job we're gonna we're gonna block
this probably with the guys with some
safety regulation but we will and that
is like
it's technically correct but I don't
know if it's going to help us in the
long term technology is happening and
will continue to happen and so we have
serious problems with automation you
can't just regulate it away that's
abandoned on a bullet wound now I agree
with them like we don't want to put all
these people out of work overnight so
there probably needs to be a transition
period where you literally say the
economy will be destroyed and 10 million
people will lose their jobs overnight so
we need to find a transition so that
this kind of thing can happen and maybe
phase it in over a long period of time
or something that's a tough one because
technology is now in improving at a pace
that we've never experienced before so
the natural uh adaptation period for
Humanity for civilization for the
economy for the the workforce to adapt
to these new technologies is is faster
than we're really capable of retraining
ourselves and I think it's only going to
get harder as Ai and other things start
to get involved so it sucks because as a
Libertarian I never want to have the
government interfere and say like oh
we're going to have to have these
truckers just sit there with the AI
device for the next decade and then they
have to go get their other jobs it's
it's going to be challenging thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time